[Music]
foreign
they will fight over it you know the the
concept of mimesis right if they can see
it they'll fight over it so you can see
Hans Island they fight over it they see
a border they fight over it and you can
see for example the franco-german border
between France and Germany you know the
Border you can't see is the border
between Twitter and Facebook and what do
I mean by that what is the border
between Twitter and Facebook well
Twitter has like 330 million users
Facebook has 3.6 billion and for each
person you could Define the Border as
for their time spent on so let's say
this that's you know 3.6 billion
Facebook users 330 million Twitter users
the total is 3.93 billion Max it might
be like 3.7 there might be an overlap
there okay
for each person you can define a zero to
a hundred percent in terms of the time
that they would spend on either their
100 Twitter or 100 Facebook right the
Border region would be those people who
are 50 50. and that might be a group of
70 million people in the world who spend
exactly 50 of their time and there's
people who are farther from the border
who are 30 70 and people who are really
far from the border near the capitol who
are 100 zero and vice versa okay what
I'm describing there is literally
something that you could compute it's
not an abstract thing if you had access
to all of Twitter's data set and all the
Facebook's data set you could compute
this here's the thing nobody has access
to both
so nobody can compute it
or you can estimate it and so on but
unless you know like Twitter and
Facebook got acquired they wouldn't be
able to literally find out who was on
the border region they could do sampling
and stuff but there's a cloud that is
descended right these gigantic Networks
cannot really see their borders that
well
they can see themselves but they can't
see what people are doing outside they
have less control in a sense right
and less visibility and so instead what
they'll they'll fight over are the
visible things
like you know the use of the network and
so on and so forth but they're going to
fight over border regions less the only
way they can fight over a border region
is to make their products so attractive
they can pull people from that border
region now by the way lest it me said
that these are like trivial things to
talk about Twitter's 330 million people
Facebook's 3.6 billion both of those are
bigger than France and Germany combined
you know
um
these are these are enormous enormous
networks it's like a huge chunk of
humanity and the fact that we cannot see
the Border region means that the entire
geography of like how humans operate is
actually changing you have to kind of
remap how you think about geography
because in physical space for example
two people you know they're they're near
each other there's a physical distance
metric and so on in digital space it's
like a bunch of islands that can snap
too like I can be near you as I am right
now and then snap away and be really far
right and that applies not just for
individuals but for entire continents so
for example in the physical world Russia
is basically always going to be adjacent
to Japan and Ukraine and Iran and so on
like Russia the country doesn't move
around that much
I mean its borders can expand and
contract with the Soviet Union it's
bigger when the Russian Federation is
smaller but it's not like it's suddenly
adjacent to Argentina right it's not
suddenly adjacent to Mexico it could you
know like it did it was involved in the
Cuban Missile Crisis at the at the
height of its power but it it's not like
projecting power all over the world
by contrast somebody like you know
vitalik of ethereum his network of
people right or you know the uh the
Solana Network suddenly this network can
be adjacent to another Network Solana
can start taking users from ethereum
it's like this huge island of like 30
million people just surfaced out of the
ocean next to Japan and started like
pulling people from them Gojira yes
right Godzilla anyway yeah exactly right
so it's like Atlantis is real digital
Atlantis this huge island what the heck
right and and it can then disappear and
vanish and you can also vanish you know
you're you're thinking kind of be like
hey you know we want to we want to cut
off those Network relations if we want
to move our Island somewhere else right
so the thing is that I'm downloading one
of about
I don't know how many 10 15 different
things that turn constants into
variables one of them is
the nation that we we take for granted
the single group of people is breaking
up into multiple Nations that are
defined by networks another is the
currency is breaking up okay a third is
the geography is changing a fourth is
the moral principles that underpin
Society are changing and so when like
all of those things are in flux you kind
of need something to catch it on the
other side because otherwise what people
will do is they will sort of try to
assert that old thing that just doesn't
exist anymore and that'll be like
something that does not acknowledge the
reality of the situation it's like
opening the you know closing the barn
door and then expecting to get all the
horses back inside when there were
forces that were more powerful than that
thing that that spread them all out that
those entropic forces you have to kind
of go to where those horses are and loop
them up and maybe have new ranches or
whatever there to to extend the metaphor